There are so many
variables in cooking,
it's always about
time and temperature.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Any recipe that
you read is going
to talk about how
long to cook something
and what temperature
to cook something.
Remember, they're
only guidelines.
It's really about being
able to appreciate
the technique and the
process and work with it.
If you make a mistake, it's OK.
Before you know
it, you'll know how
to roast a beautiful
chicken, pan roast a duck
breast with crispy skin,
or any things that we've
been teaching.
Let's get started.
Young culinarians
ask me all the time
if I can give them
some words of wisdom,
and I always give them two.
Be patient, and
then be persistent.
Don't let anybody tell you
you can't do something.
You can.
What flavor do you really want
in your vegetables or meats?
It's really up to you.
Don't take anything as a rule.
In this MasterClass, I'm
very excited to elevate
your cooking abilities.
Super tender.
Look at this dinner.
I love this kind of cooking.
To see it.
To smell it.
To experience it.
To hear it.
It truly is transformational,
and it requires,
really a commitment in time.
But if you want to
make great food,
this is what you have to do.
And remember, patience,
patience, patience.
Oh, look at that!
I want you to think about
what you want to be eating.
There are so many flavors,
textures, techniques
and recipes.
Simple perfection.
I'm Thomas Keller, and
this is my MasterClass.